[Musik]
das ist klicken geboren im kongo
aufgewachsen in berg und heute ein star
eco so
[Musik]
dort bot 2
im sommer ist den kosovo partytime aller
jungen kosovaren die im ausland leben
kommen nach hause und wollen feiern
[Musik]
es sind übrigens vom mittelstand wird
wenn man das ziel erreicht über linke
aber enthalten arbeiten
reporter über einen mann der sein glück
in einem der ärmsten länder europas
sucht unterwegs in pristina
der zwei meter große kastanie gefällt
hier in kosovo auf das scheint es zu
genießen
[Musik]
er reagiert darauf jedes winken
der kosovo ist jung über die hälfte der
bevölkerung ist unter 25 jahre alt und
bei den jugendlichen ist jeder zweite
arbeitslos
[Musik]
trotzdem die cafés sinnvoll ein ideales
publikum für kritisiert
immer an seiner seite sein tourmanager
armin seit knapp einem jahr wohnt
kastanien pristina dass da gehört zu
seinen lieblings kaffee
hier hängen viele musiker um albanisch
spricht er schon beinahe perfekt klingt
mir ist ein sprachtalent und so marke
click mir gehört auch die sonnenbrille
die villa ob tag oder nacht hat tue
nicht abnehmen
wahrscheinlich scheint es besser ist die
form stimmt
das ist aber durch den holländer
interessante produktionen kreiert und
fensterrand kosovo capital ein
kosovarischer musiker es entstand eine
gemeinsame produktion unglück nie wurde
in kosovo auf einen schlag bekannt
[Musik]
und so hatte ich eine zulage und sage ja
schon meister verdient wo wenn du willst
und von babbel muss das ganze beobachtet
worden wäre sagt herum machen wir jetzt
ist ein spezialist also und seither baut
er die marke click mehr im kosovo auf
arme in der jahrelang in der schweiz
gelebt hat organisiert seine auftritte
denn ohne beziehungen geht hier in
kosovo gar nichts
man kein tag ist es auch viele anders
als wenn er und so hat mir einfach
persönlich und als manager und krieg
mehr hat sich verletzt
auch mit anderen musikern wir sind es
nicht gewohnt dass leute in den kosovo
kommen weil wir hier ziemlich isoliert
sind
seine musik finde ich toll und
aufgefallen ist mir dass er als musiker
sehr seriös ist
klickt er ist ein cooler typ
wir sind gute freunde weil er aus dem
kongo kommt und es geschafft hat in
kosovo unsere sprache zu lernen was
wirklich nicht einfach ist
und er ist auch ein bisschen verrückt
gleichzeitig aber auch ein guter freund
er bringt uns immer wieder zum lachen
wir nennen ihn katastrophe
[Musik]
kosovo hat heute eine lebendige und
schnell wachsen der musikszene steht
noch am anfang aber er träumt natürlich
vom ganz großen geschäfte die großen in
der branche verdienen über 20.000 euro
pro auftritt
davon ist er aber noch weit entfernt
[Gelächter]
jetzt engagiert um die mittelstation
laufen wie sie sicher interessante
spiele zwischen mit dem ruder vertrag
mit dem den auftrag über acht jahre lang
hat er in der schweiz als
versicherungsberater im außendienst
gearbeitet diesen job hat er für sein
projekt aufgegeben
in pristina winter nicht irgendwo
sondern dort wo auch andere bekannte
musiker wohnen woche behindert sein dass
ich in der schweiz gebaut
[Musik]
erst nach langem zögern zeigt er uns
eine möblierte wohnung persönliche
gegenstände hatte alle weg geräumt
nur seine skier beim eingang nicht denn
jetzt nicht so speziell dass mal ein
interessantes berichten
aber ich bin nicht so gut mit reisen
möchte so sagt das ist ein zeichen der
fairness halber runde will ich die
arbeit krass brandverhütungsstelle oder
der mond zum 50
persönliches gibt ja nicht gerne preis
die marke kriegt mich so nicht
entzaubert werden
und er träumt gernegroß an
selbstvertrauen fehlt es ihm nicht denn
die zahlen ganz andere idee entsprechen
und der handelswege und darum nicht gar
nichts behauptet das stadion über
steinigungen ich mache beziehungsstatus
unbekannt für seine vermarktung ist es
offenbar besser so
instagram und snap chat sind seine
kanäle mit seiner gefolgschaft ist er
ständig in kontakt
[Musik]
ja das ist keine zeit für die familie
es ist so gut ich aber es ist ein ass
ich bin auch sehr stolz durfte sich auch
sehr viele referenzkunden
vorangegangenen wo es eine spezielle
heute geht was man frau sachen oberland
bei chronischen und übliche fahren
aufgewachsen ist gas an ing im kanton
bern
seine eltern wohnen heute in
ostermundigen mindestens einmal im monat
kommt er nach hause
er hat drei brüder und eine schwester
heute zählt nur die zwei jüngsten da ich
von mir kriegt man da muss eine lockere
also jetzt nicht übersteigen
so gebe es zum beispiel auch meine
familie kennt wird englische monate
familientisch haben wie sie aber da ist
das sehr gut
diese aber wie gesagt und so gar nicht
wann ich zurückkomme aber nicht so
kommen auch um zurück eine woche später
und dann schon mal wieder zu sagen aber
der krieg mir das ist eine gute sache
ich bin glücklich sehr glücklich die
familie ist alles für mich
der vater arbeitet heute als fahrlehrer
er nennt sich general liang im kongo war
er polizist
weil er bei der arbeit einen befehl
verweigerte musste die familie vor 29
jahren den kongo fluchtartig verlassen
kasan war damals ein jahr alt 26 tage
arbeit gefunden
ja dies jetzt nur drei wochen arbeitslos
ohne geld bekommen sowohl arbeit
gefunden bis jetzt 30 jahre
721 prozent schweizer liebe schweizer
friedland ruhig und so und ich bin will
ich hin will
das ist dem gefährt mehr so alles mit
system
das gefällt mir wirklich vater und sohn
haben eine enge beziehung dass man sagt
von allen kindern sei er dem vater am
ähnlichsten
[Musik]
gabriela der kampflos gewinner sind weg
zum zum persönlichen
[Musik]
am längsten im achten stock in bern wie
die kufen
hier hat er mit seinen freunden wenn
immer möglich fußball gespielt und hier
hatte auch die ersten wortfetzen
albanisch aufgeschnappt sprachmelodie
und der detektiv ausgesprochen
aber dieses wort steht beim fußball so
abgerechnet worden
als fußballer gern historische
ministerin
sein publikum findet klick wie überall
auch hier in bern getroffen
[Musik]
kosovo gilt unter den balkanstaaten als
armenhaus
seit 21 jahren ist der krieg vorbei
trotz kleiner fortschritte ist das land
bis heute korrupt und instabil
[Musik]
hier wandert niemand ein außer gas an
ing
er wirkt wie ein paradiesvogel
[Musik]
und beim coiffure dürfen wir seine augen
dann doch plötzlich sehen
so wie es erwartet
häufig sind sie arbeitslose maler
schnellsten jetzt nur der produzent der
show heute abend der letzte auftritt der
saison wohl jeder schon braucht gasse an
ein gutes essen mit dj toni
er gehört zu seinem team auch tonis
wurzeln sind in kosovo heute lebte aber
in der westschweiz
die beiden sprechen französisch gas als
muttersprache
er hat etwas ganz besonderes was andere
künstler nicht haben
deshalb habe ich große lust mit ihm
zusammenzuarbeiten
auch wenn es immer wieder sehr schwierig
ist mit ihm
für mich ist es einfach großartig
kompliziert
und wir bewundern
[Musik]
nicht ganz einfach hat es auch armin
erwartet schon draußen
die zeit drängt er will losfahren aber
gas an braucht noch seine sache
wieso sind die schuhe so wichtig ja gern
wissen schuhe eine gesunde ist erstmals
meine schuhe die 2
warum ich im moment am meisten
beschäftigt das war ja da waren werke
und kavlak radfahrer war vom kosovo das
walfangschiff ist ein musikstil wo man
braucht
ich warte jetzt auf die panischen
schweiz
endlich unterwegs richtung takko war zum
club hannover
letzte vorbereitungen für den auftritt
mit den schuhen
aber dann ein anruf er sollte schon auf
der bühne stehen
dass dahinter auch pause
[Musik]
ok saint germain das wort zu hangover
oder klicken und schon hier
doch nicht ganz alles im griff jetzt nur
noch rein umziehen und sofort auf die
bühne
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im sommer kommen sie alle nach hause
die jungen kosovaren aus dem ausland
dann wollen sie ihre kosovo-albanischen
idole sehen und ihr geld ausgeben
[Musik]
das in meinem turnschuhe gefallen sie
euch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein sehr gutes spiel und das ist gut so
nicht kannte ich aus in die lehrenden
julia und 14 majors kubanische rede
davor richtig hässlich tanzen
er hat richtiges geld und muss das ganze
publikum es macht spaß ihm zuzusehen
[Musik]
auf dieser bühne ist er der große star
und er verhält sich auch so
[Musik]
die kosovaren haben feuer gefangen
ob es auch beim ganz großen publikum
klick macht wird sich zeigen
[Musik]